hello everyone if you ever open the
chest book chances are you've already
seen this game but if not if it's
definitely a pretty cool game to see it
illustrates very nicely how to exploit
back ranked weaknesses and this was
played in 1920 in New Orleans this is a
Adams versus story and the people are
arguing was this game ever played or is
it some sort of an analysis but it
doesn't really matter it's it's
definitely a game to see whether or
whether or not it was it played so Adams
goes efore sorry
efore and Tory goes a five we have night
to have three and d6 the filler defense
d4e capture son d4 and now Queen
captures on d4 not Knight captor Sundy
for like in the opera game
we have Knight to c6 attacking the Queen
and Bishop to b5 now pinning the Knight
Bishop to d7 and now white plays Bishop
captures in c6 Bishop captures on c6 and
okay black has the bishop there but
white has this beautiful d4 square for
his queen a very nice central square
white plays Knight to c3 Knight to f6
now Adams castles Bishop to e7 and now
Knight to d5 and okay here black plays
Bishop captures on d5 we have capture
sandy 5 and Tori also castles and Bishop
to g5 and okay what does black play here
he was for c6 he wants to he wants to
take advantage of this isolated the D
pawn well assumed to be isolated D pawn
we have c4 d captures on C captures on
d5 a seek after sandy 5 and our rook to
e8 we have rook after a one developing
the rooks on an open file we have a five
and our work to e to Adams is preparing
to double up rooks on the file
rook the c8 putting the other broken on
the other open C file and here on us
plays a rook 81 and well blacks idea now
is the play Queen to d7 and after the
bishop moves and rook captures an e 8 so
rock out
I ate so the Queen doesn't have to
capture any 8 which would be silly
so he plays Queen to d7 and here Artemis
plays Bishop captures on f6 Bishop
captures on f6 and now this is the idea
Tory had that if rook captures rook
simply rook captures rook captures Queen
captures and well with a threat of Queen
to e1 this Bishop is very nice attacking
b2 this would be perfectly fine for
black probably probably a wrong game but
the problem is after Bishop to f6
attacking the Queen and D for Adam's
play Adams played Queen to g4 and hence
the title take my wife please he's
offering his Queen here on g4 and well
of course the Queen cannot be captured
if if the queen is captured and simply
rook captures any eight and this leads
to checkmate
after this rook captures any eight so
after this Queen to g4 move black can't
capture so he played Queen to b5 and
well here the Queen is defending the
rock on e8 and well also attacking this
rook on e - now but here Adams plays a
queen to c4 now offering his Queen and
c4 and again black and Catherwood the
Queen or with the rook and c8 but
whatever black plays here if he captures
the Queen he gets made it on e8 for
example rook captures and rook captures
with checkmate like that very nice so
after Queen to c4 Tori played Queen to
d7 running with the Queen yet again and
well Adams continues to try and to try
and offer his Queen he plays Queen to c7
and well the blacks the black Queen is
almost that was almost out of squares
again if the rook or the Queen captures
the Queen at c7 bug gets checkmated on
e8
so he plays Queen to b8 and here Adams
plays a four and well what does what
does black play here if if he plays
anything other than grabbing this a for
pawn he loses the game instantly
so he does he plays Queen captures on a
force still guarding this rock on e 8
and now Adams plays rook to e4 now he's
offering the Queen still in c7 he's
attacking blacks queen with this rook
and well what does black play here only
move the engine is giving is actually
rook to f8 to somehow stop checkmate but
he doesn't really have anything he has
to go Queen to b8 and now the Queen no
longer has this fourth rank available
and here Adams plays Queen captures on
b7 offering his Queen for the final time
and now the black Queen has no more
squares this c6 square is unavailable
the d7 is unavailable a4 is unavailable
and well whatever black plays either if
he captures between this little eats the
checkmate and even if he doesn't have
the Queen to be 7 for example what can
you play you can play rook captures on
e4
of course not capturing the Queen but
Queen captures on c8 with check and well
there is nothing for nothing for black
to play here Queen to e8 Queen captures
with check rook captures and again the
game ends with rook to e8 checkmate so
yeah after Queen to b7 of course mr.
Tory resigned and like I said it doesn't
really matter if this was a real game or
was it an analysis it's it's definitely
one of the greatest so yeah this was a
short one I hope you enjoyed it as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you all for watching and I'll
see you soon